[Music]
Disney Princesses bring us magic through
the big screens they're brave they're
stubborn and they tell an important
story did you know that the oldest
Disney Princesses were 21 and Snow White
was only 14 doesn't it make you wonder
what they would look like now make sure
you subscribe to our Channel and hit
that like button if you love Disney as
much as we do now join us as we discuss
what Disney Princesses would look like
today
Cinderella Cinderella was first seen on
the big screens in 1950 and it soon
became one of the most beloved Disney
stories out there can you believe it has
been more than 60 years since Cinderella
first premiered because Cinderella was
so popular Disney kept on re releasing
the movie on five different occasions
over the years to allow generations of
all ages to enjoy the story Cinderella
was 19 in the movie and although she was
always treated badly by her stepmom and
her stepsisters she remained kind and
loving this of course paid off so what
was Cinderella look like now a talented
brazilian artist had an amazing idea and
created an 84 year old Cinderella and we
absolutely loved her the hair the makeup
the clothes the necklace she almost
looks like she could be the Queen from
The Princess Diaries she's got the smile
that shows she's still just as
kind-hearted what do you think would an
85 year old Cinderella have any kids or
grandkids but here's a more important
question has her shoe size changed in
the third movie Cinderella reveals her
shoe size is actually incredibly tiny
have her dainty feet stayed the same
through the years Cinderella
also taught us an important life lesson
be courageous and be kind Snow White did
you know that Snow White was first a
book published by the Brothers Grimm in
1812 and the first snow white movie came
out in 1937 it's one of the most famous
fairy tales in the world and it's still
popular with children as well as adults
Snow White was originally meant to be
blond which was the hair color of most
European fairy tale female characters
around that time however they changed
her hair in looks to make her more
relatable in the story Snow White is
just 14 in fact she's one of the
youngest Disney Princesses followed by
the fifteen-year-old Jasmine from
Aladdin so here's what Snow White would
look like in 2017
she'd be 94 years old styling the same
length hair turned gray did you know
that the woman who voiced Snow White had
such a unique voice she had to sign a
contract that said she was never allowed
to play in another movie again the
original Snow White's look and parts of
her life were based on a German countess
who was born in 1533 doesn't she look
like a princess we bet she'd be very
flattered if she knew her life became a
popular fairytale Aurora Sleeping Beauty
premiered on January 29th in 1959 but
did you know that the movie took six
years to make nevertheless Aurora's
charm her story in the movies happy
ending captured the world's attention an
Aurora remains one of the most popular
princesses to this day
Aurora was 16 years old in the story and
if she aged with the movie this is how
she would look in 2017 the Aurora that
you can see on the right is 72 years old
and she has certainly aged very well her
long blonde hair turns shoulder-length
gray and her face has matured but this
look only adds to Aurora's graceful and
loving personality Aurora is definitely
a popular princess but so is the actress
who gave Aurora her voice her name is
Mary Costa she's 87 and she has an
interesting announcement for the
Sleeping Beauty fans in 2016
Mary always signed and replied too many
letters Sleeping Beauty fans sent her
but on her 86th birthday
the actress made an announcement that
she can no longer reply to the letters
but don't worry she said she'll still do
the in-person signings when you see her
and she'll continue to help children
believe in their dreams Belle we can't
talk about favorite princesses without
mentioning Belle
can we the french 17 year old stole the
hearts of many after they have watched
the enchanting story of Beauty and the
Beast Beauty and the Beast premiered in
1991 and it instantly became a hit who
wouldn't fall in love with this story in
the charming characters that made us
angry laugh and cry give this video a
thumbs up if Beauty and the Beast is
still one of your favorite stories did
you know that the story was based on a
French fairy tale published in 1756 that
was just a bit darker than the Disney
classic you loved in fact you can also
find an Italian and a Norwegian version
of stories that inspired the popular
movie Belle was incredibly beautiful
outspoken and a curious
seventeen-year-old bookworm who was wise
beyond her years so what would she look
like if she aged with the movie he or
she is at 41 still looking absolutely
fantastic we love her shoulder length
hair guess how many animators and
artists worked on the Beauty and the
Beast movie six hundred no wonder it's
still so popular after all these years
jasmine along with Snow White Princess
Jasmine is one of the youngest Disney
Princesses did you know she was just 15
in the story and she looked absolutely
flawless Princess Jasmine is a favorite
of many and we can definitely see why
she's free-spirited confident and
headstrong in fact she was so gorgeous
the Aladdin producers asked the artist
to redesign Aladdin as he was much
happier than the Persian prince you know
the movie first aired in 1992 it was the
first animated movie to make more than
200 million dollars in revenue jasmine
was 15 in 1992 but this is what she
would look like these days he or she is
aged 38 and of course she's still as
gorgeous as ever her striking eyes
really make her stand out from the other
Disney Princesses but her inner beauty
is just as important and we absolutely
love how young jasmine always stood up
for herself
we hope the 38 year old jasmine would
have the same personality and that she
and Aladdin would have a family and go
on Amazing Adventures princess Jasmine's
looks were partially modeled by the
actress Jennifer Connelly and we
definitely see the resemblance
it's Princess Jasmine your favorite what
do you think of her as a 38 year old
Merida there is always a debate whether
Merida is a Disney Princess but she is
in fact the first Pixar character that
received her princess crown and we can't
leave her out of this list this
illustration comes from a tumblr user
called pansy Ella who created a series
of illustrations on what Disney
Princesses would look like in the
modern-day world but we have to say we
are completely in love with this version
of Merida from brave we can totally
imagine Merida being chosen for Taylor
Swift's bad blood music video and we
love this illustration the fighter that
she is the modern-day Merida is wearing
an interesting dark outfit and she's
definitely ready to rock one thing many
love about Merida is her beautiful curly
hair that makes her stand out from the
other princesses did you know that her
wild hair was animated from 1,000
500 individual curves that grew into
more than 100,000 pieces of hair now
that is a lot of hair Merida has had
ventures and free-spirited in the modern
world Merida definitely strengthened her
personality Merida was 16 in the movie
which was made in 2013 what we love
about this Disney princess is that she
never really gave in to the stereotype
of a princess even though she was the
first Pixar character to receive the
honor of being a princess in 2013 so
what do you think of Merida in the
modern world Rapunzel the same artist
that designed Merida also Illustrated
many modern images of Disney's Rapunzel
and this image is our favorite it seems
like the modern-day Rapunzel grew back
her hair we're also in love with her
outfit the denim shorts for the simple
white tee but is that a phone in her
hand
it looks like the modern day would turn
Rapunzel into the queen of selfies
Rapunzel's quirky personality was
actually inspired by three Hollywood
actresses Reese Witherspoon Natalie
Portman and Amy Poehler all added their
humor to the Disney Princess Rapunzel
holds her secret power in her long hair
but do you know how long it would be in
real life the creators of the film said
her hair is 70 feet long which is pretty
impressive
however this tumblr user has an
interesting theory about Rapunzel in her
hair they completely doubted the laws of
Disney's physics and stated the Rapunzel
would actually need double the amount of
hair to come down the tall tower in the
way that's presented in the movie we're
talking about an impressive 140 feet of
hair the user even takes a dab of the
fact that she was able to use her hair
to stop mid fall which is completely
impossible there is just one explanation
for this
it's how Disney magic works Pocahontas
this drawing was also illustrated by the
same talented artist we can totally see
a modern-day Pocahontas doing the
catwalk she's absolutely gorgeous what
do you think a fashion model by day a
crime-fighting hero by night or has
Pocahontas settled down from the
adrenaline into the city life although
we can't see her arm tattoo this poke
honest is totally rocking a gorgeous
designer outfit would she be an
established model or is she in the
running for America's Next Top Model
where ever she would be she certainly
seems to know what she's doing with her
life and we are officially jealous is
this what you'd expect from a modern
version of Pocahontas Pocahontas was
always able to stand up for what she
believed in she was compassionate and
she was never afraid to go after what
she wanted
a modern-day Pocahontas would definitely
be just as strong minded and she would
never care about anyone else's opinion
at least that's what we think did you
know that Pocahontas character was so
complex it took 55 animators to design
her she's definitely not your average
princess and we bet that this modern
version of Pocahontas shouldn't be taken
for granted either Mulan this modern-day
Mulan belongs to a very talented
deviantART user Mulan was 16 years old
in the movie but she has proven to be a
very impressive Disney character that
didn't take no for an answer
what we love about Mulan is her strength
and her independence her character is a
portrait of the same named Chinese
warrior whose original story came from a
Chinese folk story
the modern Mulan is sporting a very
typical trendy look we love that she has
moo shu on her hoodie she's also
sporting some really cool yellow colored
shoes and simple jeans
besides jasmine Mulan is also the only
princess who is seen wearing pants
instead of a skirt or a dress which we
can also see on the modern-day Mulan
Mulan also gave us one of the most
important life lessons ever to never
give up
if you ever need a character who's all
about girl power look no further than
Mulan we bet a modern day Mulan would
have no trouble fighting for human
rights inequality and she'd definitely
have something to say about gender
discrimination give this video a thumbs
up if mulan's your favorite disney
princess because she just might be ours
Ariel The Little Mermaid story was first
released as a book written by Hans
Christian Andersen in 1837 and became a
Disney movie in 1989 in the story the
sixteen-year-old Ariel longs to leave
the ocean and see what it's like to live
her life on land
of course her father is very much
against this wish but that doesn't stop
the stubborn Ariel from visiting land
where she actually falls in love with a
human The Little Mermaid story is among
some of the most popular Disney classics
but have you ever wondered what Ariel
would look like today check out this
image in 1989 Ariel was 16 which would
mean that she'd be about 28 years old on
the right picture it looks like the life
on land straightened Ariel's hair and
gave a bit more definition to her face
did you know that the look of Ariel was
actually based on what Alyssa Milano
looked like when she was a child
the charming actress confirmed the fact
sells the animators took images of
Elissa and created the iconic aerial how
cool is that
if you could be turned into a Disney
princess which one would you choose and
why who's your favorite Disney Princess
let us know in the comments below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and click the subscribe button for
more Disney videos check out 10 most
epic Disney movie themed bedrooms ever
we'll see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]